[Music]
this is interesting you are now the star
of a movie based on a book that you know
based on the the buddy cop thing that
you and I did you know how I waited I
waited what did I wait - it's five years
yeah to get a call from a you know an
agent or at least a Booker or somebody
I got you started in the movie business
with that appear yes no I did never it
never took off and I had to do it you
know I had to do another movie well this
is interesting because you you wrote the
book and they came to and they said okay
we want that you want to make this movie
let me make a movie about this very
important topic which is the well it is
it is incredibly important of its its
widening inequality of a wealth income
opportunity in this country it's got you
know we are now more unequal than any
other advanced economy we're more
unequal than we have been in a hundred
years and people aren't paying attention
to it and so a very talented young
director Jake Kornbluth came to me and
said we want to make I want to make a
movie and I said you know you can't make
a I mean that people are not gonna be
under tained this is gonna you know he
said I think this can be funny I think
it can be heart-wrenching I said you
know I've written books my books are the
kind of books that once you put him down
you can't pick him up you know a lot of
books I've written but he he he's
brilliant he's a genius and he made a
movie that the screenings we've done
people people cry they laugh they and
they get it well let's let's talk about
the issue which is what you say our
country is at its most in equal that
it's been in a hundred years and you're
talking about the rich the concentration
of wealth among the richest which
percentage of America this is the top
one percent one in tenth of one percent
look at Conan I am NOT a class warrior
I'm a class warrior weirdo rear we're
done I'm worried about what's happening
in this society and we are not paying
enough attention to it and the problem
is there's no way this economy can
function when the vast middle class and
everybody
wants to join the middle class doesn't
have enough money to buy all the things
that the economy is capable of producing
and at the same time our democracy is
basically the hands of a smaller and
smaller and smaller richer and richer
and richer number of people right who
are bankrolling the politicians